[Musique]
bonsoir Clara bonsoir Joanie bonsoir
Comment ça va très bien je suis trop
contente de vous retrouver vous m'avez
manqué un vraiment ah ouais alors Joanie
c'est toi qui a contacté qui nous a
contacté Cyril Hanouna et moi pour faire
une demande en mariage incroyable à ta
chérie c'est ça j'ai toujours eu
l'habitude de faire des grosses
surprises à Clara et quand j'ai vu le
tweet de Cyril je me suis dit c'était
l'occasion de faire une surprise
incroyable donc tu es toujours dans les
chaussures prenantes et j'ai toujours su
que la demande en mariage ça sera un bon
j'imaginais pas ça aussi énorme mais je
savais que ça allait être quelque chose
d'assez grandiose mais j'imaginais pas
autant et c'était très réussi on est
d'accord bon cool alors dites-moi vous
êtes ensemble depuis le lycée c'est ça
comment ça s'est passé votre rencontre
c'était au lycée donc j'étais en seconde
et c'était le terminal hyper voilà côte
de popularité les filles le populaire
celui qu'on regarde ah mais non mais je
connais mais j'adore oui c'est vrai
qu'en plus c'était comme ça moi j'arrive
petite seconde qui vient d'un collège
privé voilà bah oui et donc je me
souviens la sonnerie avait retenti et du
coup tout enfin beaucoup de monde dans
les couloirs d'accord et là je vois un
mec je le regarde ses yeux bleus et donc
on avait un ami en commun j'ai dit mais
c'est qui
et j'ai dit mais c'est qui lui il est
trop beau et en fait il s'est empressé
d'aller lui dire et du soir même il m'a
ajouté sur les réseaux donc c'était le
fameux terminal ouais qu'est-ce qu'il
fait que votre amour est tout aussi fort
au fur à mesure des années et que ça
tient évidemment
tout ça et il y a trois mots c'est
respect communication
et la confiance
ça c'est important ouais c'est le fait
de de se dire que tout ce qu'on ressent
tout quand ça va pas le droit c'est pas
toujours tout beau tout rose mais la
communication c'est le plus important et
dans tous les plus important et c'est
comme ça qu'on passe ensemble les
épreuves effectivement la confiance et
il fallait avoir beaucoup de confiance
en Joannie parce que quand il t'a fait
la caméra cachée il t'a quand même caché
quelque chose et ben écoutez regardons
tout de suite cette incroyable caméra
cachée c'est pour vous et c'est pour
vous regardez
[Musique]
coucou ça va ça va papa je te présente
Joannie alors sa chérie c'est Clara ils
sont trop mignons c'est un premier amour
qui est magnifique et c'est le bon donc
maison mais attends justement je te fais
un tour du propriétaire
alors regarde
voilà donc ça c'est le plafond bon ça
c'est la cuisine
[Musique]
donc là c'est le salon voilà donc
ça moi j'ai l'impression que
oui parce que quand la maison sera
vraiment belle vous pourrez vraiment
commencer votre vie de famille en fait
c'est ça
en fait c'est son rêve je crois que là
on lui réalise son rêve si on lui fait
une belle maison
à bientôt bisous Ciao
notre défi transformer ce chantier en un
joli petit nid d'amour afin que ce soit
le meilleur des corps pour la demande en
mariage de Joannie et on a de la chance
Clara est en déplacement pour quelques
jours on doit se mettre directement au
travail et pour ça on a besoin de vrais
super-héros
alors je vous explique j'ai rencontré un
petit couple très mignon qui s'appelle
Joannie et Clara Joanie veut demander
Clara en mariage mais le hic c'est le
nid d'amour qui n'est pas un nid d'amour
d'accord autant dire que il y a tout à
fait
il y a pas de lumière il y a pas de
chauffage il y a pas d'exister
moi le défi que j'ai envie de vous
demander c'est vous me faites peur de
faire ça en trois jours trois jours mais
c'est pas possible alors moi je peux
peindre
Shahid a accepté de relever le défi avec
ses équipes en seulement une journée ils
ont déjà bien avancé mais il reste
tellement de travail
[Musique]
il nous reste pas beaucoup de temps on a
bien avancé mais il nous reste beaucoup
de travail l'électricien tu vas aller
faire le tableau s'il te plaît vous vous
allez vous occuper du sol Maxime et
Chavanne vous j'ai quelque chose pour
vous Stéphane montre-leur s'ils ont pour
eux
je suis la reine
[Musique]
pendant que la peinture sèche et que
toutes les équipes continuent de
travailler dans la maison direction une
grande enseigne pour acheter tous les
meubles dont vont avoir besoin Clara et
Joanie
bonjour Cassandra bonjour Comment ça va
ça va merci beaucoup de nous accueillir
ici avec plaisir je te présente Joanie
on a envie de lui faire une belle maison
vous commencez de zéro c'est ça
si vous n'avez rien je vous propose
qu'on aille voir les canapés
trop mignon ça c'est dans son style ça
c'est très mignon et en plus est-ce que
tu as vu ce que j'ai vu c'est pas vrai
le canapé Clara c'est incroyable merci
beaucoup Cassandra un canapé c'est bien
mais c'est toute la maison qu'il va
falloir meubler
[Musique]
après avoir bossé toute la nuit pour
être prêt avant le retour de Clara on
attend plus qu'une chose notre shopping
[Musique]
c'est par ici
c'est génial 2
on vous attendait
la maison c'est le grand jour moi je
suis là je vous aide aussi les deux bras
en plus il va falloir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pendant le montage des meubles on va
chercher le plus important la bague
bonjour
c'est par là je commence à deviner
[Musique]
bienvenue dans l'univers du bijou et de
l'Alliance coucou Anna
[Musique]
il veut faire plaisir à sa chérie
donc là vous avez des solitaires avec un
diamant central c'est très joli vous
avez celle-ci qui a un petit peu plus
[Musique]
de l'or rose c'est très actuel le rose
pour les princesses
elle fait très princesse en fait
à bientôt
quand Clara est partie en déplacement
voilà comment était sa maison elle ne se
doute absolument pas de l'incroyable
surprise que lui réserve Joanie
[Musique]
c'est incroyable bon c'est le moment
johanie je te donne la bague
qu'on a choisi qui est la bonne vague
qui est fantastique tu es prêt pour ta
demande
il fait une grande surprise on va
rigoler un peu quand même OK et moi je
te regarde en haut dans les caméras
d'accord allez bonne chance merci
on va un peu jouer avec les nerfs de
Clara et pour ça on a préparé une petite
caméra cachée le scénario est simple une
météorite s'est écrasée dans son jardin
et des fans sont venus voir l'incroyable
événement
[Musique]
des policiers et les chaînes d'infos
entourent la maison
[Musique]
tu arrives bientôt ou pas
la maison
qu'est-ce qui se passe devant la maison
il y a la police il y a la presse
de me faire peur par contre et mes
animaux souvent la maison et toi tu
serais devant la maison
j'ai déposé Rodin chez tes parents
et Roméo il doit être dans la maison bah
oui je n'ai pas le laisser dans la
maison mais qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est
pour ça que je te dis viens moi j'ai
besoin de toi là
je te rappelle
elle réagit bien
[Musique]
sûr
ça arrive les enfants c'est bon ils sont
là les gars
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
je vais vous expliquer la situation très
rapidement madame en fait il y a une
depuis une météorite qui est tombée sur
le secteur et du coup ça attire les
illuminer un petit peu comme la troupe
qui est ici
la seule chose c'est que on est en lien
avec la préfecture ils ont
malheureusement une liberté de pub c'est
n'importe quoi on peut pas leur donner
accès jusque là ils ont jamais tenté de
rentrer on peut éliminer mais en tout
cas ils font mal à personne non mais
elle peut rentrer chez elle
maintenant
je sais pas il me dit que le préfet
de vous garder avec moi
pour aller dégager mais là
bonjour
on n'est pas là pour vous déranger il y
a une pluie de météorite qui s'est
rabattu un peu partout vous devriez
sourire parce qu'elle est tombée sur
votre maison enfin le jardin de votre
maison n'importe quoi une plus de
météorite c'est une bénédiction il y a
que des énergies positives qui sont
descendues alors attendez parce ne pas
franchir ne pas franchir ne pas franchir
le champ magnétique je suis désolé mais
je vais devoir vous faire
je sais que ça peut paraître merci à
quoi russe je sais simplement que vous
paraître étrange j'entends parfaitement
mais il ne peut pas détruire ce champ
magnétique c'est que de l'amour et
si ça vous dérange pas je vais bien vous
remettre ce collier qui va vous apporter
nous on veut juste rentrer vous
rentrerez il y a pas de souci
je vous laisserai rentrer il faut qu'on
communique plus vite c'est fini on va
pas on va pas se mentir
mais il va nous laisser Clara c'est
cosmique Clara c'est très cosmique
voilà
je sens beaucoup d'amour entre vous dans
votre cœur
j'ai demandé juste de vous faire un
câlin plaisir
on sent le champs
[Musique]
c'est un truc de dingue
on a senti que tu étais très stressé
pendant le tournage est-ce que tu peux
nous raconter déjà je suis très timide
déjà faire ça pour moi déjà là c'était
une grosse preuve d'amour de me montrer
comme ça de montrer que j'aimais Clara
tout ça et du coup bah oui moi j'étais
stressé c'est pas tous les jours qu'on a
à la télé chez soi
Clara toi quand Joannie t'appelle en te
disant il y a du monde devant la maison
ça va être compliqué de rentrer
qu'est-ce que tu ressens je suis
dépassée je suis énervée parce qu'en
plus je suis fatiguée j'avais le voyage
juste avant bon alors là tu décides de
sortir de la voiture même si tu dis la
vie de ma mère je sors pas de la voiture
pourquoi tu dis ça mais parce que je
voulais pas sortir je voulais retourner
chez ma mère je voyais qu'il y avait en
fait il y avait un gros bordel devant
chez moi et je voulais pas l'affronter
je voulais vraiment aller au confort
entrer manger voir mes animaux ce que tu
m'avais dit que notre chien était chez
ma mère du coup je voulais qu'il gère le
problème et vas-y tu m'appelles est
terminée bon alors avant de regarder la
demande en mariage de Joanie pour Clara
c'est le moment de jouer avec notre
nouveau jeu gratuit la roue de la chance
vient en sème avec les magasins But
notre partenaire si tout comme Joannier
Clara vous rêvait de transformer votre
intérieur de changer votre cuisine nous
vous proposons de tenter de remporter un
chèque cadeau d'une valeur de 4000 €
ainsi que de nombreux cadeaux tout au
long de la soirée le principe est simple
pour participer il vous suffit de
scanner avec votre smartphone le QR code
qui s'affiche sur votre écran et tournez
la roue interactive vous avez jusqu'à la
fin de l'émission pour participer alors
bonne chance à tous
[Musique]
de retour sur C8 dans l'émission viens
on s'aime une émission où on parle
d'amour de manière tout à fait originale
des demandes en mariage juste dingue à
la Cyril Hanouna on est là pour mettre
des paillettes dans votre vie et puis
des beaux ballons c'est ce qu'on a fait
au final pour vous Clara et Joannie et
bien on va voir cette caméra cachée qui
est juste dingue regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu te rappelles comment c'était avant
[Musique]
je te montre un peu la suite tu veux pas
parler
[Musique]
c'est pas terminé je te montre la suite
[Rires]
non mais je veux juste te montrer encore
il faut que je regarde de partout
c'est sérieux là ce que je vais dire la
surprise c'est pas seulement ça
je t'avais dit que j'allais te faire
vivre ta vie comme dans les films du
romance donc là tu es parti trois jours
tu as besoin c'était un tout dit tu
rentres aujourd'hui il y a les
transformer
je voulais dire que tu étais tout pour
moi
et tu voulais te demander ce
spectaculaire
aujourd'hui c'est le bon moment
Clara
oui vraiment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
félicitations
alors en fait Clara on t'explique un peu
avec Joannie avec Cyril Hanouna on t'a
fait une grande surprise on voulait que
ta demande en mariage soit spectaculaire
Giovanni il nous a vraiment montré qu'il
était une belle personne et du coup on
voulait vraiment te faire ce plaisir
donc on espère que ça te plaît
et alors cette bague
elle est magnifique j'ai pris un truc
comme ça je sais pas tu la regardes tu
te rappelles que c'était quelque chose
de grand et elle est parfaite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu es trop mignon qu'est-ce que ça vous
fait de revoir ces images
j'ai une émotion le fait de voir qu'il y
avait autant de monde derrière tout ça
en fait toutes ces personnes qui étaient
là vraiment pour vous c'est ça
j'étais perdu on se pose la question
quand tu rentres c'est vrai qu'il y a
une caméra en face de toi tu ne la vois
pas je suis dans une bulle en fait
je me remette dans le contexte que c'est
chez moi et j'ai vraiment du mal et puis
il me dit qu'on continue on continue on
avance moi je croyais que c'était juste
les travaux après quand il s'est posé le
genou et là aussi t'as dit arrête tu as
dit non en fait c'était déjà trop pour
moi
plus elle est reculée elle faisait des
gestes justement non c'était déjà
beaucoup trop les travaux et c'était
c'était énorme alors j'ai encore une
surprise encore une surprise encore une
surprise je
aujourd'hui s'il y avait pas eu Cyril
Hanouna et cette belle cette belle
caméra cachée cette belle surprise vous
seriez où toujours dans la cabane
on dit pas de c'est une maison en fait
Joannie il est malin mais en fait il
reculait les travaux pourquoi et moi ça
parce qu'il savait apparemment que la
télé
hors de moi de voir que les travaux
n'avancaient pas je les ai mais appelle
le plaquiste s'il te plaît appelle le
plombier après après moi je devenais
folle en fait je folle c'était source de
conflit par moments je savais que
c'était pour économiser pour faire
l'étage à faire maintenant vous habitez
dans votre maison Clara c'est vraiment
ta maison ouais ça y est c'est ma
cuisine c'est ma maison c'est ton canapé
alors Clara il paraît que toi tu as cru
que le lendemain la production allait
revenir pour ramener les meubles ah oui
j'ai dit mais c'est chez moi vous
repartez avec tout il me dit non c'est
chez toi tout est à toi j'ai vraiment eu
du mal à comprendre et j'ai mis deux
semaines à redescendre de mon nuage à
comprendre que c'était ma télé à
comprendre que c'était ma cafetière
c'est incroyable incroyable merci
beaucoup vous étiez adorable tout le
bonheur du monde continuez comme ça
des meubles du tapis du chien et tout ce
qui va avec